MALE SPEAKER: I'm just
going to quickly introduce
Michael Taft to my right--
I guess to your left.
Michael's been working
with us for a few years.
He's been doing detachment days.
And he's also done some
training for our volunteers
in the gPause program.
And it's really great
to have him here
to talk about his new book.
But before that,
he will be leading
a 20-minute guided meditation.
And so with that, I'd like
to turn it over to Michael.
MICHAEL TAFT: Good morning.
Let's just start by meditating.
We're going to dig right in.
So if you're ready, let's go.
Begin by finding
your meditation seat
and settling into a
comfortable posture.
And as you do that,
already allow awareness
to contact the body sensations
associated with sitting.
So feel, for example,
your butt and thighs
touching the chair, and really
tune into that sensation
as clearly as you can.
Feel your feet on the floor.
You might feel you're back
on the back of the chair,
if you're sitting in a chair.
And in whatever
other way, just tune
into these basic
sensations of sitting.
And just sort of
yourself to arrive.
Next, sit up straight,
allowing your spine
to extend upwards
towards the ceiling,
allowing awareness to contact
the body sensations up and down
the spinal column, feeling
yourself coming to attention,
feeling your back and neck
coming into alignment,
and noticing, perhaps,
a background sense
of brightness or
wakefulness that
comes into awareness
when you do that.
Good.
Now just invite your
entire body to relax.
Allow yourself to
release tension,
to let go of any tightness,
and to just open and soften,
generally.
And as you're doing
that, allow awareness
to contact any sensations
of relaxation or opening
or softening that's happening
anywhere in your body
so that you're really
directly contacting
sensations of relaxation.
So, for example, allow
the muscles of your face
to release and relax and let go,
releasing any frozen mask you
have on and allowing your
face to become supple and soft
and relaxed.
And as that's occurring,
just tune into those feelings
of relaxation.
Feel the muscles of your face
gentling and softening, maybe
becoming pleasantly neutral.
And allow that pleasant, relaxed
sensation to impact awareness.
And next, relax your
neck and shoulders.
Allow your shoulders
to just kind
of float down and
your neck to release
and your throat to open.
And again, while
that's happening,
point your awareness at the
muscles that are relaxing
and actually tune into
those feelings, those body
sensations of release and those
body sensations of opening.
And if there's something
that's painful or tight
or doesn't want to relax,
don't fight with it.
Just let that be the way it is
and find some other part that
is gentler or softer or
more open and focus on that.
Good.
Next, let go of any
sense that you're
going to use your arms
or hands for anything
and just allow them to come
to a complete, total repose.
And then just open up and relax
your upper arms and your elbows
and your forearms and
your wrists and hands.
And just feel those muscles
lengthening and loosening
and notice, if you can,
how that feels good.
And allow that good feeling
to really impact awareness
so that you're feeling
it deeply in your body.
Next, relax your
belly, letting go
of any tightness, any armoring,
any tension in the belly,
and just allowing it to
be fully, fully relaxed,
fully open.
Just let the belly flop out.
And notice as you do
that, that it allows you
to breathe much more deeply.
There's much more room in
your abdomen for breath.
And allow awareness to
contact the body sensations
of your abdomen
relaxing and opening,
your belly softening
and releasing
tightness an
armoredness and tension.
And just feel how
good that feels.
Allow that to really
enter awareness.
And next, just like you did
with your arms and hands,
allow your legs and feet
to let go of any sense
that you're going to
do anything with them.
Allow them to just
release and relax
and let go and come
to a complete stop.
And then, as you notice
that relaxation beginning
in your legs and feet,
tune in and allow
that to be the focus
of your awareness.
And allow the releasing of
those muscles and the gentling
down of the legs and feet to
be something that really fills
your mind so that you're
actually down in the limbs
with awareness, feeling
them relax and let go.
Good.
Now just zoom out
and allow awareness
to cover your entire body.
And just, once again, invite
your entire body to relax.
And any place that feels relaxed
and open, just tune into that
and feel it as
clearly as you can.
You may notice
that you're having
mental pictures of that
area or you're thinking
thoughts about that area.
But what you want to do
is feel that relaxed area.
Feel it in your
body with your body,
and allow that good
feeling of that relaxation
to fill your awareness.
Good.
Next, we're just going to scan
the body part by part and tune
into not only relaxed
sensations but any sensations.
So begin with your feet.
Just feel your feet.
You can do them one at
a time or both together.
But feel the bottoms
of your feet,
and Feel how they're touching
your socks and your shoes.
And you can actually
feel the shoes.
And feel the tops of your
feet and between your toes.
Feel your ankles.
And just keep tuning into these
sensations of the body part
from within the body part.
Allow awareness to be down
inside that body part,
feeling the sensations.
Next, feel your legs.
Allow awareness to contact
the shins and the calves,
even the bones in the
legs, in the lower legs.
And just see if you can really
allow that to fill awareness,
exploring, in detail, all
those little sensations
in the right leg
and the left leg.
They may be very everyday
sensations, nothing special.
But they're really sensitive.
There's a lot of detail
in your leg sensation.
So just keep exploring it
with openness and curiosity.
If there's anything
that you don't like,
if there's pain or tension,
just allow that to be there.
Just feel it.
Don't fight with it.
Let it be.
And then keep feeling the rest
of the legs and the thighs
and the long bones
of the thighs,
this time not
relaxing on purpose,
but just allowing the
sensations in the legs
to be exactly the way they are.
And see if you can
begin exploring--
with a lot of curiosity,
a lot of openness--
is this sensation in this leg
different than that sensation
in that leg?
Is any part of any sensation
changing or moving?
And what's the textural
quality of the sensations?
Really dig in and explore.
Don't just kind of touch
base or check the box.
Really keep your
curiosity awake and alive
and explore the
sensations in detail.
Good.
Next, move to your
whole pelvic region,
front and back, side to
side, and inside the pelvis,
maybe including your
leg Joints, your hips,
if you didn't include
that previously.
And feel all the sensations
in the viscera there
and the muscles and the bones.
There's a lot going on.
And again, if you're getting
a lot of mental images
of that region, just let
those go and come back
to simply feeling
the pelvic region
from within the pelvic region,
allowing the sensations to be
any way they are, not trying
to change them or control them,
but simply feeling them deeply.
And then move to your
lower abdomen, your belly
and your lower back.
Feel the sensations
of your belly muscles
and your back muscles
and your lower spine,
feeling into your viscera,
feeling the expansion
and contraction of the
belly and the kidney regions
with each breath and
just really tuning
into that whole region, so
alive with sensations, so vital.
And just notice how
the front of the belly
feels different than the
back of the belly region.
Feel the inside of your
spine in your belly.
Just generally explore, noticing
the quality of the sensation
in your stomach
and on your sides,
just allowing it to
be any way it is.
Good.
And next, move to your
upper torso, your chest
and upper back and underarms.
You might feel your
whole chest and rib cage
expanding and contracting
with each breath.
You might feel your
lungs filling up with air
and emptying of air.
You can feel the inside
of your spine up there
and all your ribs.
There's a lot going
on, a lot of sensation,
very interesting sensation.
Just keep exploring that.
Just keep giving it your full
awareness, your full attention,
allowing whatever sensations
are arising to arise,
not trying to fight
them or control them,
simply feeling, noticing
that you're breathing.
Good.
Next, allow awareness to
contact your arms and hands.
You can get as much
detail as you want here,
feeling each finger
individually,
the palms of your
hands, the backs
of your hands, down inside
the hands and wrists exploring
your forearms-- the
bones of your forearms
and the muscles on both
sides-- allowing awareness
to contact the elbows.
It's a lot of sensation
in your elbows.
Now normally, you
go around all day
just ignoring your elbow
unless it's in terrible pain.
But even right now, just
see, if it's not in pain,
just see if you
can really explore
the feeling of the
elbow on both sides,
just remaining curious
and open, exploring
with a kind of innocence,
a kind of openness,
ready to find whatever's
there and greet it.
And then move on to your upper
arms, your biceps and triceps.
Just feel those
releasing and opening.
And notice whatever
sensations are there,
allowing that to just be.
Good.
Now feel your shoulders
and neck and throat,
not particularly trying to
loosen it or relax it or open
it, but just
feeling what's there
and cultivating a real
sense of allowing,
a real sense of
acceptance of whatever you
find in your shoulders and
your neck and your throat.
Just noticing the difference
between, for example,
the bony part of your neck
and the sort of openness
of the throat and feeling
all the muscles in between
or feeling into the complexity
of a shoulder joint.
There's so much going on there.
It's a lot of different
types of sensation,
especially if you
get very detailed.
It's quite interesting.
And next, move up to
your face and head.
There's a tremendous amount
of sensation in your face,
so you can explore your
lips and your nose, even
inside your nose or inside
your mouth, your eyes
and your forehead
and your cheeks.
You can feel your ears
and the back of your head,
and then even your jaw
muscles and jaw joint and then
inside your sinuses
and inside your head.
Just feel whatever sensations
are interesting in your head,
remaining as curious
and open and as clear
as you possibly can.
Feel into whatever
is most interesting
in your face and head.
And just keep allowing
awareness to contact it,
not trying to change
it in any way,
not wishing it were
different, but just
allowing it to be whatever
it is, whatever way it is,
and then allowing the
feeling of the way
it is to really
saturate your awareness,
really fill your mind so
that all your attention is
on that feeling.
Good.
Now expand the scope
of your attention
to cover not only your
face and head but also
your neck and shoulders,
and just feel all that.
Whatever's interesting in those
regions, just tune into it.
And then expand awareness
again and to cover
your face and your head and
your neck and your shoulders
and also your arms and hands.
And again, with
curiosity and openness,
just directly contact whatever
sensations in the body
are interesting there.
And then add to that your
upper chest and upper back
and the inside, including your
heart and lungs and so on.
And then add to that your belly
and the back of your belly
and your kidney
region and the inside
there, where your stomach
is, so that it's everything
from your head all the
way down to the stomach.
And just feel all that it
wants and tune into anything
that's interesting.
And then add to that
your pelvic region
and your legs and your
feet so that now, it's
your entire body, all body
sensation, right to left,
top to bottom, front to back,
the entire body, one unified
field of sensation.
And just tune in in whatever
way to whatever's interesting.
And just stay open.
Just stay relaxed.
Stay curious, accepting
whatever you find.
Good.
Now you can end the
meditation and just very
slowly and gently,
open your eyes
and allow yourself to
move around a little bit.
Thank you.